Transcription: Clare Borradaile
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je vous parle un tout petit
peu de comment je suis arrivé ici.
Un jour, en discutant avec un homme,
je lui disais -
c’était il y a quelques années -
que je voulais arrêter
de faire de la musique.
Il m’a presque interdit de faire ça.
Il m’a dit : « Tu ne peux pas.
- Pourquoi ?
- Parce que nous sommes
les médecins du cœur. »
Alors j’ai pris un peu de temps
pour penser à cette phrase
que j’ai un peu comprise.
J’ai dit : « Mais comment
devenir un médecin ?
Il faut que tu vibres
sur la même fréquence que
la source divine de la création.
- Oh ! Ok.
Et comment faire ?
- Tu fais avec ce que cette
même source divine t’a donné,
c’est-à-dire la créativité.
Et par la créativité,
puisqu’on imite un peu ce qui a rendu
tout possible sur Terre et dans l’univers,
on vibre à cette fréquence.
Cette fréquence,
c’est la fréquence de l’amour. »
Je vais vous chanter une chanson
qui s’appelle : « Je suis là. »
Je l’ai écrite en 2017,
c’est important de le savoir.
Si vous suivez le texte,
vous comprendrez pourquoi.
(Musique)
Qu’est-ce qu’il y a ?
Je te fais de la peine.
Tu n’arrives même pas à me regarder.
Tu préférerais que je m'ouvre les veines
pour pouvoir enfin respirer.
C’est ma présence qui te dérange.
Tu aimes mieux croiser des robots
qui seront sages comme des anges,
comme les moutons d’un troupeau.
Je me suis libéré
de l’emprise de la société.
J’ai appris que pour être libre,
il faut sentir son cœur qui vibre.
Et peu importe mon karma,
je dois l’accepter, c’est comme ça.
Je ne me mettrai pas à genoux,
je reste droit et tiens debout.
Je suis là pour te parler un peu de moi,
de cette vie faite de hauts et de bas,
car j’ai traversé des mers pour être là.
Et sur ce rivage, il y a toi.
Peu importe ce que l’on pense tout bas,
lorsqu’on croit entendre
s’approcher mes pas.
J’adorerais pouvoir
te prendre dans mes bras,
car la paix est mon unique choix.
Je ne vais pas te mentir,
je ne devrais même plus être là.
Mais la mort est venue m’avertir
qu’elle était très heureuse sans moi.
Je n’ai pas vécu des choses faciles,
donc je suis là pour témoigner
que chaque saison est utile
pour permettre aux autres d’exister.
En voulant changer l’être humain,
en le traitant moins bien qu’un chien,
on lui inocule un venin
pour qu’il achète son vaccin.
Et quand arrive un gars comme moi
qui dit haut ce que tu penses tout bas,
on lui fait bouffer des pilules
et on l’enferme dans une cellule.
Je suis là pour te parler un peu de moi,
de cette vie faite de hauts et de bas,
car j’ai traversé des mers pour être là.
Et sur ce rivage, il y a toi.
Peu importe ce que l’on pense tout bas
lorsqu’on croit entendre
s’approcher mes pas.
J’adorerais pouvoir
te prendre dans mes bras,
car la paix est mon unique choix.
Avant de rejoindre ma mère là-bas,
j’irai rendre visite à Gladys et Papa
et qui sait, peut-être que ce jour-là,
une femme se tiendra à mon bras.
Ohhh... Oh, oh, oh.
Ohh... Oh, oh oh...
Ohh...
Je suis là pour te parler un peu de moi,
de cette vie faite de hauts et de bas,
car j’ai traversé les mers pour être là.
Et sur ce rivage, il y a toi.
Peu importe ce que l’on pense tout bas
lorsque l’on croit entendre
s’approcher mes pas.
J’adorerais pouvoir
te prendre dans mes bras,
car la paix
est mon unique
choix.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
(Musique)
Cette chanson s’appelle « Nos pensées »,
comme tout ce que l’être humain a créé
a été précédé par au moins une pensée.
Il faut vraiment soigner ses pensées.
Mes regards ont laissé échapper
une larme pour l’humanité.
Nos cœurs se sont immunisés
contre les pleurs du monde entier.
On a fini par ignorer
les raisons de notre arrivée.
Le monde nous avait acceptés
pour que nous puissions l’admirer,
connaître enfin la sérénité.
Notre amour s’est dissimulé
derrière les pleurs d’un nouveau-né.
Les efforts de nos mères,
le courage de nos pères.
se sont sauvés de nos pensées.
Du premier au dernier être humain,
on s’est passé le même témoin,
tous dépendants de nos voisins
et passagers d’un même train.
J’irai crier sur tous les toits.
Nos différences nuisent à nos joies.
Nos cœurs se connaissent mille fois.
Ne laissons plus ces faibles rois
briser nos vies encore une fois.
Notre amour s’est dissimulé
derrière les peurs d’un nouveau-né.
Les efforts de nos mères,
le courage de nos pères,
se sont sauvés de nos pensées.
A chaque fois que nos erreurs
ont fait couler du sang, des pleurs,
on a continué, comme un bébé,
de suivre les chemins tracés.
Ni Dieu, ni maître pour nous guider.
Ohhh...
Hé...
La la la la la la la
la...
la, la, la, la, la,
la, la, la,
la...
La, la, la, la, la !
Ma foi ne diminua pas.
L’espoir m’a pris entre ses bras.
J’unis ma musique à la Terre
pour que demain ma poussière
s’allie au rythme de river.
Notre amour s’est dissimulé
derrière les peurs d’un nouveau-né.
Les efforts de nos mères,
le courage de nos pères,
se sont sauvés de nos pensées.
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Je terminerai ce petit set musical
par une chanson,
cette fois en anglais,
qui s’appelle « Something Has Changed ».
[« Quelque chose a changé »]
(Musique)
(Chante en anglais)
Oh je sais que ça fait longtemps,
que la vie nous a donné du fil à retordre.
Parfois, les hommes tombent,
je veux être plus proche de maintenant.
Je sais, c’était dur d’arriver
ici, sans rien à donner.
Je sais que ça fait longtemps,
que la vie nous a donné du fil à retordre.
Des larmes silencieuses
coulent chaque jour.
Il n’y a rien de plus à dire.
Des larmes silencieuses
coulent chaque jour.
Maintenant je fais ma propre foi.
Quelque chose a changé
en moi.
Je le sens en ce moment,
quelque chose a changé.
Je le sens jour et nuit.
Trop de sentiments dans ma tête,
Je ne peux pas vous dire mes pensées.
J’enlève les oiseaux des fleurs,
et prends soin de mon génie.
Oh non, j’ai dit
que ma vie ne fait que commencer.
Je sais que j’étais presque mort
perdu dans ma tête.
Des larmes silencieuses
coulent chaque jour,
il n’y a rien de plus à dire.
Des larmes silencieuses
coulent chaque jour,
Maintenant je fais ma propre foi.
Quelque chose a changé
en moi.
Je le sens en ce moment.
Quelque chose a changé.
Je le sens.
Da da da da da yeah yeah,
Quelque chose a changé en moi.
Je le sens en ce moment.
Quelque chose a changé.
Je le sens.
Je le sens. Oui, je le sens.
Jour et nuit.
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup.